[Music]
and just when do you think things can't
get any worse
Camp Rock goddamn - if he saw my first
review of Camp Rock you know I thought
it was a real piece of but it was
kind of so bad it's good and it was just
a piece of but you know what it
made me laugh how bad it was this one is
definitely on the same level if not more
but what little shred of naivete the
first film head is totally erased here
and it's parading around like it has the
most soul and humanity and it has none
of that absolutely none of that you feel
every manipulative cookie
cutter moment for what it is it put me
in a bad mood I'm here to bitch about it
okay so once again Mitchie is returning
to Camp Rock she's surprised to find out
though that Camp Rock is now a musical
yeah not like they sit around and sing
songs or perform on stage like in the
first one no literally everybody has a
dance number ready if someone just says
hey I want to sing about something
suddenly the whole camp joins in and
they're all synchronized and it's like
High School Musical the first note
wasn't like that so why is this suddenly
like that it's like it's suddenly in the
spider-man movies it turns into a
musical okay that did kind of happen but
people hated that too but the guy who
runs the camp is kind of bummed out
because it just so happens another rock
camp opened right across from them camp
star run by his ex band member that he
threw out because he just didn't make it
about the music man and now he's vowing
to destroy Camp Rock at all costs how do
I know this because he literally
announces it to the entire camp chemstar
found it not so coincidentally by my out
to destroy me former bandmate axel
Turner that was freaking awkward enough
to tell their entire camp this but to
literally sweeten the deal they
parachutes some mores on the crowd
leading to probably my favorite line
graham crackers why does that make me
laugh so much it's just so clueless and
lifeless graham crackers has every
please bland performance in one
uninterested line Graham's
back is camp star invites camp rock over
to a bonfire which I swear to God is run
by the brother of the guy who ran Cobra
Kai and we asked someone if they want to
perform if she says yes does one of many
planned songs and big shock they show
them up with all these expensive dance
numbers and hey offers the Camp Rock
counselors on the spot to join their
team to which of course they all go over
if there are any Camp Rock counselors or
staff you'd like to make the switch I'd
be more than willing to double your
salary
yeah it's this kind of movie guys even
the blonde girl who's the villain in the
first one that they became friends with
at the end she goes over there Christ
didn't I call it when there's no
repercussions this just repeats
itself this means
oh no camp rock has to be cancelled
because they have no counselors but of
course Mitchie her friends and naturally
the Jonas Brothers all come together to
be counselors but oh oh
counsellor is hard as they all
contribute their one personality trait
of being clumsy yeah nobody else has any
other personality traits it's just
clumsiness oh I relate to them now but
when camp rock goes over to challenge
camp star master Cobra Kai says why
don't we televise the whole thing
what just like that he has connections
to broadcast this to millions of people
they of course agree which pisses off
the guy who owns camp frog because he's
like oh no camp rock will close forever
talking about millions of people are
gonna see you even if you lose the phone
ring off the hook you get all this free
attention but nope he thinks this is
gonna be the end which forces Mitchie to
work even harder but oh no is she losing
the soul of the music is she losing the
fun of camp camp star has the money and
moves but do they have the love do they
have the genuine human spirit no and
neither do you you corporate piece of
I'm sorry this really pisses me off
when Disney and the Jonas Brothers are
saying you got to be more authentic you
got to be more real and they just go
into this song sequence with
all the auto-tuning and nothing about it
feels authentic it feels manipulative
and bullshitty is that even a word I
don't care
making it a word it's Paul shitty even
Michie in the first film I said I could
see her actually kind of being a good
actress she had kind of this awkward
smile that looked a little geeky but I
was still kind of charming here that
smile never goes away if anything they
like perfected it and it's on her face
24/7 I just want to rip that little
smile off I see it so much she seems
like a robot they all seem like robots
none of them seem like actual people but
we should listen because this is the
authentic side that has the heart and
soul oh shut the hell up if anything I
actually side with Cam star they say
they're there to make people stars and
they say it has a lot of sacrifice and
giving things up and they're right
anyone that knows anything about the
entertainment industry will tell you
this if camp rock just wants to be a
little fun camp where you play some
songs and sit around a fire that's fine
but why the hell do you have celebrities
there the Jonas Brothers are at your
camp as soon as you do that it's not
gonna be about just sitting around
singing songs and having fun and maybe
it would come across better if the
people seem like real people but not one
iota of them ever does the only actress
who sometimes seems genuine is the
daughter of Cobra Kai yeah they do a
stupid Romeo and Juliet thing with
star-crossed lovers on each camp and to
her credit when she talks she sounds
like an actual human being you don't see
metaphorical charts and graphs all
around her saying hey this'll hit a
certain demographic or you gotta have
this funny thing happened because
numbers indicate this is where this
stuff happens she sells it like an
actual person everyone else sounds bland
forced and forgettable even the songs
this is a musical and like 90% of them
are entirely pointless you could have
cut them and not miss a thing I don't
know why this movie pissed me off more
than the last one I mean the last one
was really bad too but something about
this one just saying that it understands
like real are real poetry the real human
condition and it's so clearly doesn't I
feel like naive kids are gonna look at
this and say I understand what it means
to be an artist I understand being a
musician I understand the sacrifice and
being real and no you don't and neither
does this movie it doesn't even get a
hint of it both art and entertainment
should be taken seriously if you're
saying you're a movie that understands
both
this is your understanding of it then
you're clearly showing your corporate
strings being pulled yeah said enough
this movie sucks by graham crackers
[Music]
you